your tongue is so sweet really my twill
is so sweet
kim went from resting jealous face to
eyes wide open no no she did this
after uzman announces that he's
considering marrying her what's your
drama
yes
if everything goes well
we plan to get together being together
like getting married
hey
maybe the gifts did work
best
ps4
we're gonna talk about it plus my
feelings are kind of hurt because elena
feels some type of way after caleb
doesn't show any affection during their
first night together i just wasn't
feeling it there's
things getting in my head i'm realizing
our physical differences and johnny's
friend this one right here
makes an offensive joke about ella's
weight i have struggled with being
overweight since i was in kindergarten
let's talk about it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia happy
2022 this year it's gonna be good to you
corny i know
but you better claim it
[Music]
all right this season is finally warming
up
i can already tell it's about to get
real did you spend the night in a room
or
i did not spend the night in her room
the morning after kim gifted oozman with
the macbook pro in ps5 he tells his
manager badmiss and assistant slam t
he's catching feelings
she got me a laptop she got me
the latest video game yeah wow well
you're catching feelings uh i must be i
i do feel like i care about this woman
slam t's silence says it all hi kim hey
fast forward to when kimberly joins them
they start to discuss guzman's business
meeting with east african rapper rosarie
and for some odd reason oozman felt the
need to invite kim
i guess to make good tv because other
than that
it makes no sense no no no no no no i'll
bring you but maybe you should go by
yourself oh maybe you should go by
yourself
somewhere someone
yeah well i think that that's that
that'd be cool though yes that would be
very cool sure but you'll go alone
dude no i'm going with your money right
okay yeah i'm going to come back why you
breathe like that
what's that what's that about oh
someone's in trouble
i don't know what's going to go down
between kim and slam tea by the end of
this trip but the tension has been
building since the moment they met i
super fun
don't call me that now kim has this
assumption
that he and badmiss set up this meeting
with rosarie to try to sabotage her
relationship with oozman
when really what they're probably trying
to do is
[Music]
i mean isn't that their job a part of me
is wondering if his team planned this on
purpose like to push me out of the way
so maybe they can show me like hey this
is the kind of woman that useman should
be dating if i do see any kind of like
flirty flirty thing going on with usman
and this chick then i mean i will get up
i'll flip the table and i'll walk out
because i don't play that so
kim's talking about flipping a table
over him flirting yet she told her
friends she would be okay with him
having multiple wives if usman has
multiple wives i feel like that it's
okay because i love him wait what
yeah
i'm curious
1921. that's the year i was born
kim not the jokes going into the
restaurant for usman's meeting
but her sense of humor didn't last long
due to her anxiety about rosary joining
them yeah i should have just stayed at
the hotel maybe i should have hmm yep i
feel like it's good if i should bring it
because like if i leave you in the hotel
you feel like okay
maybe it would have been better
i don't know why you're getting this
different because like you shouldn't be
this up
okay you shouldn't be because like you
know who is coming you know why she's
coming i don't know her okay i've never
met her oh oozman
the look
okay
he then proceeds to ignore her
listen
one
i know you hear me i know you hear me
lucky for oozman kim keeps her composure
but then enters rosarie who i must say
seems like a super cool chick
now usman does flirt with her a little
bit at first oh what is magic maggie is
water he compliments her accent your
tongue is so sweet
really nice so sweet but it's harmless
although understandably it makes kim
feel uncomfortable i know this is a
business meeting but damn i literally
feel like a third wheel right now you
know she's beautiful she's young and i'm
sitting over here like am i the grandma
in the group or you know what's going on
i really want to have like dancers
because i love to have dancers no
problem at all
after usman and rosary talk business so
i know why you're here
oh why is kim here rosa gets to the big
question because let's not forget this
is her business meeting too she had no
clue kim would be there but i appreciate
the way she handles it she cuts straight
to the chase and also makes sure kim
feels seen oh why is kim here just to
look pretty
i will tell you what
she she happened to be a fan
and we've been talking to each other for
long and like we're having this period
that we want to see each other you know
oh you haven't you haven't this is the
first time with me except for like video
you know video chat wow we're here and
we're getting to know each other so fun
and more yeah fun and more i love that a
fan with potential oh wow
rosarie asked usman what kim has the
potential of becoming and compared to
how he reacted to kim booking herself
the honeymoon suite because she has
intentions
it's kind of too much because
like
i'm not a boyfriend yet his next answer
is a shock
if everything goes well we plan to be
together
so we end up getting been together like
getting married
kim's heart just soared through the roof
that is so beautiful yeah yeah that's if
things go well no she did this
no the truth is oh wow
why is he why does he have a grin like
he's
in fashion
oh now you're blushing wow i know i know
[Laughter]
usman hasn't really mentioned marriage
to me before
so to hear usman say this to rosary i
was like wait what
it really blew my mind
mine too
i just hope he's not playing
i'll be honest y'all at this point i
have no clue what usman is doing he's
hard to read
i don't know if it was the gifts that
gave him that extra push or if he might
really be in some more mature women it
could be one of those tried at once now
i like it scenarios
i don't know i just hope he understands
what these words so we end up getting
being together like getting married
sound like to a woman who is extremely
into you
now her hopes are probably
here it really blew my mind
all right moving on to 27 year old alina
from russia and 28 year old caleb from
arizona i think you look great
but
you're smaller than i thought
oh is it weird for you
it's different these two decided to meet
for the first time in turkey
wait is it just me or is that cat huge
that's a big cat
anyway
back to alina and caleb they decided to
meet in turkey after talking online and
over the phone for 13 years but during
their first night together caleb chose
not to be affectionate with alina and he
was honest about why we didn't have sex
didn't even kiss i just wasn't feeling
it there's
things getting in my head i'm realizing
hard physical differences
and i was really tired from this trip
it's not the ideal setup for magic to
happen what he's saying is
understandable but thankfully alina is a
strong confident woman who knows who she
is
yes caleb's lack of affection the first
night hurt we always wanted to meet each
other
and to do stuff with each other and then
it finally happens and he just does
nothing like it's illogical but she's
being patient and still giving him an
opportunity to warm up to her hmm
that's nice hugging you finally yeah
so it's worth the wait
i don't know yet
i do feel like he's warming up to me a
little bit he's got big arms which kind
of like
fit all around me and i feel so small
and
i don't know protect it and he has a
really nice body and it's fun to touch
him and
yeah want to touch more
now enters elena's best friend elijah
who joined her on the trip and is
dedicated to protecting her at all costs
finally
for a number of reasons he's having some
major doubts about caleb being the man
that elena deserves and needs in her
life which is rubbing caleb the wrong
way did she kiss her at least
we did not kiss man
[Music]
my first impression of caleb
isn't that good
he didn't even kiss her last night it's
really weird for me i feel like he's
being divisive and putting issues where
there's not as the day goes on these two
clash even more
especially after elijah notices that
caleb is not that much of a gentleman in
his opinion oh i want to go up here and
check out the second floor you want to
come up here lena no
there's only a few steps for me to carry
you i can wait here
okay we won't be too long okay okay
enjoy your company then
my company is best company you don't get
some things will be
a little hard with lena because
maybe she
don't want to
go somewhere
maybe
it's just uncomfortable for her so
you need to really get used to it
and respected she seemed to be fine
waiting down below the guy who wants to
be
near such a beautiful woman like elena
is needs to treat her like the queen
but i didn't see
uh that much from caleb today can i have
a friend like elijah
i know some of you might think he's
doing the most but that's a genuine
friend and they don't come by that often
that notice that you're fulfill your
glass first not hers and you don't even
have an invitation americans usually are
not gentlemen
i wish somebody would have told me that
a long time ago
so good choice elena i mean i'm not it's
not my fault he's american although
alina's time with caleb started off a
bit rocky after elijah leaves and allows
them to be alone alina finally gets that
kiss plus more oh my god how are you i'm
good
[Music]
well hey there
hi
you know i spoke to elena before the
season started about being the first
little person in the 90 day franchise
and she educated me on a lot including
the term ableism which is the
discrimination of and social prejudice
against people with disabilities i'll be
honest i've never heard that term until
she mentioned it and i know i'm probably
not alone so i want to share with you
what she had to say for some reason
there is not much talk about ableism
uh
and how people
can say
degrading things about those who have
disabilities maybe something can change
with the show because more people
would know that it's not okay to
i don't know
shame someone for their height or for
like using a wheelchair or something
last but not least
my name is johnny
i'm 34 years old as johnny is in the
process of making plans to leave china
and travel to idaho to meet his cosplay
queen ella in person he sits down with
his friends for lunch and he has to clap
back at this one for making fun of
ella's weights
oh
it's always the one that shouldn't say
something that says something
his comments were unnecessary at least
johnny and ella are getting some action
[Music]
do you think that we will be able to
have some fun sexy time with the wigs
what do you think yeah that's great
moving on if you thought johnny was
using ella to get to america this
episode might change your mind i just
really wanna
meet her he reveals all he's sacrificing
just to spend three months with her
right now i'm working in a electrical
car manufacturer if he gets his travel
visa within the next week he plans on
quitting his job
mind you he's the sole breadwinner of
his family and he would also have to
leave his son stoney behind with his
parents
which is his main concern but
very important slowly for him
and also he may need my help
because i call it flights from america
to china there are very few very limited
so once i fly out it's going to be a big
challenge to fly back
that's a problem
yeah i know that that's scary
yes
i feel it's such a hard
decision
to be so far away from my son
i'm really so nervous about that but
johnny says ella has helped him through
some of his darkest days and he's lonely
so getting to her is worth the risk i
know that johnny is risking a lot to
come over here to be with me and
sometimes i really worry that he might
decide that i'm not worth all the
sacrifice
and that is really terrifying to me
because i definitely have put a lot of
my eggs in this one basket
well next week it looks like johnny is
going to hit some roadblocks including
his parents who aren't so fond about him
leaving yesterday
you covered you so long i mean you call
us
you should do nature
once i fly to united states it's going
to be hard for support my parents i hope
i'm making the right decision
what
what's wrong ella what's happening
i am worried this is the first step to
him never being able to make it to the
united states
in the past there have been 90-day
couples who never actually end up coming
together
i wonder is that going to be ella and
johnny
we'll see all right 90 day fans fam make
sure you stick with et because we are
covering it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you